When I was ten, my future looked so clear to
me.
Married to Josh Hartnett with two kids.
Driving a Honda Odyssey.
Not a bad life.
Got another one coming.
Push! What's going on?
There's been a mistake. I came here to see
one of my friends. He had a heart attack.
Don't worry. You did great with the first
two. Just keep pushing. You're having
triplets.
I'm- triplets?
And now...
baby three.
But here's the thing about childhood
fantasies. They almost never come true.
Congratulations. It's a podcast.
Mabel. Mabel!
Mabel.
The doctor said I can finally go home.
What?
Yeah. No no no no no. The man had a full on
heart attack five days ago. You rush him in
here, stick in a stent to prop up his creaky
arteries.
Nobody said creaky.
Now you're just going to go and send him off
into the world.
Mabel, I need to get back. My show opens in
two days and my star is about to be charged
with murder.
Doctor, maybe
you should just run a few more tests to be
sure.
His body responded very well to the stent,
although I'm sure it was quite a scare for
all of you.
I wasn't scared.
Oh, is that so? You know, I was just
pretending to be unconscious when I heard you
wailing. I can't let him go.
Come back to me, you sweet son of a bitch.
I was doing a performance for the nurses. They're big fans
of mine. What am I going to do? Not be
Charles Hayden Savage?
Oh, admit it, you're obsessed with me.
I can't believe I actually missed this. Come
on, Putnam, we've got work to do.
Yes! Let's go. Yes, yes.
For starters, if Loretta made up her
confession to protect her son, don't we need
to prove that her son is Ben's real killer to
get her out?
Loretta's been in jail a few days now. I
wonder if she's shaved her head and gotten
all jagged.
I can't let her take the fall for this. She's
the love of my life.
Love? I thought you were just hooking up.
Oh, we hooked up.
We hooked up big time.
We hooked up and down and every which
direction. You name a.-
I promise we will get her home to you.
No matter how many face tattoos she has now.
Charles, did you learn anything from those
police interrogations we so skillfully
recorded?
Actually, we haven't watched them yet. We
were sitting by your bedside this whole time.
Mabel wanted to wait so you could be a part
of it. Little softie.
No, I didn't, it wasn't like I was like,
let's hold hands and watch it together. It
was just like. Shut up.
Okay. We're focusing on Dickie. Loretta
clearly thinks that he's guilty. That's why
she confessed to protect him. Ben was
poisoned and then later pushed down the
elevator shaft. But we don't know whose hanky
he was holding on to when he died. I mean, it
could be Dickie's.
We know that someone wrote Fucking Pig in
lipstick on his mirror, and we have footage
of him in a heated moment talking to an
unseen person, possibly a lover.
Can we just take a beat to appreciate how
magical this is? The three of us reunited at
last, investigating as one. Mabel, you stayed
faithful to the podcast. You should take the
lead. Just the besties are back.
Oh, that should be our opening line.
You just said Mabel should take the lead.
Can I make a suggestion? I narrowly escaped
death. And now you won't let me live.
Wah wah wah wah wah wah.
This is fucking weird.
Okay, okay.
The besties are back.
It may take two to tango, but it takes three
to solve a murder of an ill fated movie star.
Welcome to a brand new episode of Only
Murders in the Building.
Perfection.